[Music]
hello and welcome the dear hencken job
or as I prefer to think of it to you
John and Hank it's a comedy podcast or a
two brothers answer your questions give
you devious advise talk about death and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon John what did the
pirate say when he turned 80 what did
the Pirates say when he turned 80 I'm 80
terrible it's terrible I do um I do have
some wonderful news for you this week
it's sad but it's still really wonderful
okay Hank it's out of Kentucky I'm just
gonna read you the headline from The
Associated Press Kentucky town mourns
its first female mayor Lucy Liu a dog
that's very sad
but also not date line Rabbit Hash
Kentucky you heard that correctly Rabbit
Hash Kentucky the town of Rabbit Hash
Kentucky is known for a string of highly
esteemed mayors one of whom died this
week she was 12 and a dog was a dog that
would be a very different story she was
12 and a dog she was 12 and a dog I mean
good on Rabbit Hash though maybe her
first female mayor should have been a
human being well maybe but to be fair
Lucy Liu was rabid hashas third dog
mayor so they've had good luck with dog
mayor's in the past I guess and a by all
accounts Lucy Liu was a wonderful mayor
and she will be sorely missed not just
by her family but also by the larger
community of Rabbit Hash but don't worry
I'm sure that they will elect a new dog
mayor soon in in small communities
people are busy and I know people who
will take the the yoke of public
servanthood aren't always the ones that
you want to actually do that job I would
argue that's also the case
a larger community just led by dogs
not only should dogs vote dogs should
also vote for dogs all right Hank before
we get too political let's answer some
questions from our listeners this first
one comes from Liza who writes dear John
and Hank I don't smoke but most of my
friends at college do I always turn down
cigarettes when they offered them to me
but now I've started an internship where
most of my colleagues also smoke I
usually go outside with them while they
smoke so I can keep chatting with them
but my boss keeps offering me cigarettes
I've said multiple times that I'm not a
smoker and I don't want to become one
but she keeps asking if I want one how
do I not give in to peer pressure when
it comes to my new boss probably
breathing in secondhand smoke right now
Liza Liza where do you work in 1962 I
don't I don't understand this is are you
sure they're not vaping yeah I mean I've
checked to see if these are in fact
Jules yeah I am I am shocked that you
were having this particular problem in
this particular year it's not not a
problem it is a problem and it's
frustrating and honestly if I were you I
wouldn't go out to breathe that
secondhand smoke I would just get some
extra emails written but then you
wouldn't get all that good socializing
time with your boss and everybody knows
that chatting up your boss is important
so I don't know like like this is
literally why people who don't want to
smoke end up smoking and addicted to
cigarettes so you are in the situation
right now where that like this happens
to people and it's happening to you and
I don't want it to happen to you yeah
Liza I would just say like of course I
don't want to smoke first I don't want
to cigarette have have you seen the news
you see the sign behind the cigarettes
and on the side of the cigarettes and
the picture on the back of the cigarette
right yeah actually that may be what I
would do next time your boss offers you
a cigarette you should pick up the pack
and say maybe I'll have a cigarette oh
wait no the Surgeon General is warning
this is a bad idea right here on on the
package Hank we need to move on because
even though I quit smoking 17 years ago
talking about it makes me think about
smoking so let's just go let's move on
comes from Megan who asks dear Hank and
John we have magnifying mirrors that
make things bigger and funhouse mirrors
that do all kinds of crazy things why
don't we have prescription mirrors
surely they just have to cut the glass
like they do for eyeglasses I just want
to be able to fit my makeup brush
between my face and the mirror and be
able to see sin see Roly Megan good try
good try
Hank why can't we do this I assume
there's a reason well I think we can
actually it's just though it would be
expensive and you'd have to do it for
each individual person so nobody's ever
thought of it I think Megan may have
invented something Megan you have your
first Hank thinks it's a million dollar
idea two hundred dollar idea I don't
know there may be limitations to this
technology that I don't know you would
have to be the same distance from the
mirror at all times but like if Megan
chooses a distance that she prefers to
do her makeup at then we would be able
to create that focal length and have I
think have it be in focus for her I
don't know if that's necessarily true
because I'm not an optics expert but I
think that it would work maybe we'll
just magnify it now I'm now I'm
second-guessing myself yeah I'm not sure
it would work in reflection John I just
wanted to let you know that there is a
US patent on a prescription mirror oh it
is a thing that exists it was patented
in 1999 so it's not that recent of a
thing and it was by Leon Goldstein and
Arthur Dorf so congratulations to them
on their patent no idea if that is a
thing that has gotten used yet it looks
very fancy you want to know something
interesting about the guy who invented
that sure John I mean prepare to be
really really surprised okay I have met
him really
which one dr. Dorf
well tell me about dr. Dorf I met him
when I was having all kinds of weird eye
problems that turned out to be orbital
cellulitis oh he has a bunch of he's a
bunch of patents well there you go he
seemed like a nice guy he knows a lot
about eyes so that's who you should talk
to right called call dr. Dorf
that's art that new podcast call dr.
Dorf oh my god what a great podcast idea
does dr. Dorf have a podcast or he's not
just wasting his life saving people's
eyesight I mean if you have a name like
dr. door if you can't not have a podcast
it's rules
the answer is he does not have a podcast
did you look it up yeah did you check
Georgia does have a podcast he's a 68
year old pop to trick him oh he's an
ophthalmologist and also now that I've
seen a picture of him I don't think I
saw him I think I might have seen one of
his colleagues anyway so there you have
it you just been invented it's just not
necessarily commercially available yet
correct it turns out that it was a good
idea but not good enough
Oh Hank I wish you were able to say that
to yourself more often this next
question comes from Wesley who writes
Dear John and Hank I've struggled with
confidence issues for a while now when I
was an undergraduate I didn't want to
switch my major because I felt like I
wasn't smart enough but I did well when
I did switch my major and after that it
took a while to convince myself to go to
graduate school but I did and I did well
now I'm trying to get into medical
school but I still struggle with feeling
like I don't actually have what it takes
maybe I feel less physically anxious
when I try new things now but that
nagging insecurity is still there do
people ever really feel confident or
does everyone just try to do things
anyway and see if they work out Wesley
in my experience and of course this is
different for every person you you end
up feeling confident at something after
you do it for a pretty long time like so
going into medical school it's not a
time in which I think most people will
feel confident they will feel confused
and scared and not sure if they will be
able to do this thing that many people
end up not being able to do and dropping
out of and so like that's normal and I
think that people who go in feeling
confident are just
is likely to drop out as people who go
in feeling like they're not sure
yeah Wesley here's what I would say I do
not want a medical student who is
brimming with confidence I don't even
want a new doctor who's breathing with
confidence I want you to be terrified I
mean not a lot of like you're cutting me
open with a scalpel like I don't want
you to be like 2 2 on the edge of Terror
but yeah like I want to live and so I
want you to care about whether I live
right because I don't want it Wesley to
think at least six times is this the
correct medication to prescribe to this
patient on the first day I've ever
prescribed medicine yeah which is almost
definitely the case it seems like you've
got a great mentality for being a doctor
overconfidence is is overrated yes yes
it might be the most overrated virtue of
the 21st century like it can get you
elected president but it doesn't make
you good at being president that's a
good example John thanks all right well
before this becomes a political podcast
which would be a disaster we're gonna
move to our next question from Jamie who
asks dear Hank and John so in my family
oh it's still gonna be political John I
forgot about this question so in my
family we share two cars among three
drivers most the time my mom drives the
minivan and I Drive the Camry can I take
my parent's window stickers off the back
windshield it's just that we have
different opinions about the
organization those window stickers are
supporting and I don't want to be
advertising for an organization I don't
like do I just put up with it like you
would put up with a roommates MK Dons
poster reprehensible but still their
property or do I get some say because
I'm the one the person behind me in
traffic is actually making assumptions
about not a Lannister or a Frazier Jamie
if they're a Jamie Fraser I don't know
if that is oh yes the hot hunk of love
in the Outlander series
Oh God Jamie Fraser whoo doggy
what were we talking about we were
talking about bumper stickers John I
yeah well so I I talked about this one
with Catherine and she was like it's not
your car you can't you can't do anything
to it like it's not your property and
then but then this is a great point at
the end because I do think things about
people based on their bumper stickers
and I wouldn't want someone to think
something about me that I don't believe
it's like well it's not a bumper sticker
it's a thing in the window that you can
tell that's and I in my question back oh
it's removable and replaceable they
don't even have to know just do it right
and if it's a bumper sticker maybe you
could just like put a little sign up
that like that covers it or that says
like my mom likes this organization
totally you get a second bumper sticker
with an arrow that says my mom likes
this but I totally disagree you just put
it on the moment you leave like you pull
out of the driveway stop half a block
away put it on and then when you're
coming home you take it off or you could
just get it another bumper sticker that
says there is a diversity of opinions
among the people who drive this car
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
actually a really wait Hank I just
accidentally had a million dollar idea
there is a diversity of opinions among
people who drive this car bumper sticker
is now available at dftba.com right now
I'm making it available for pre-order
before the pod goes up okay it's there
because because of course that's true
I mean most cars I I guess maybe most
cars aren't driven by multiple people
but in my household that is definitely
true and there's a diversity of opinions
in my household or in for example thinks
that Woody Guthrie's car song is the
only song this is a pretty good song I
mean or it has better tasted my kids
he loves that song yeah yeah no I think
that is probably a good solution I was
thinking what would what would I do if
my roommate had an MK Dons poster and
the answer is that on my side of the
room I would be like there is a
diversity of opinions in this room about
whether or not to support a franchise
that stole their league place from
another team anyway I think this is a
good solution I think we've I think
we've solved the problem for once for
once we did it all right Hank this next
question comes from Martha who writes to
your John and Hank what do you do when
people you're friends with keep making
fun of someone else you're friends with
high school sucks Martha I don't know
like that's gonna depend on who you are
and I'm not doing anything about that is
definitely an option like if if you
don't want to like cause like any ruckus
in your friend group like like that is
an option but but I think it also like
you could do the thing where you tell
your friends that you like that person
and you don't really get why they're
being mean to them and they're like
maybe there is a way for them to realize
that what they're doing isn't isn't nice
and is cruel and and like you don't
think that it's funny or fun and it it
is making you think less of them not
more of them maybe that's feedback that
they can incorporate and and like it
won't disrupt that dynamic too much also
maybe it does disrupt the dynamic so
much that like it doesn't feel like a
comfortable friend group for you anymore
and maybe that's because like these
aren't the people that you're supposed
to be friends with yeah the only thing
I'd add to that is that sometimes you
don't feel safe to say those things and
if you don't feel safe to say those
things I understand but I also think
that you know the the person who's being
made fun of and who probably feels and
is extremely vulnerable if you can
represent that person and represent
their personhood to your group of
friends it might help them to see that
the person that they're making fun of is
not like an idea or an object but is
instead an individual human who
you know feelings and and worries and
fears and vulnerabilities just like
anybody else yeah and I mean this is uh
it's such a hard time of life when we're
trying to define ourselves and and often
times define ourselves in opposition to
other people or like to to like we are
all are suffering from like in high
school times but also other times we're
suffering from you know feeling insecure
and not valuable and trying to trying to
push down someone else to make us feel
bigger to try and shrink down the size
of someone else to MIT to like make us
look bigger in comparison as a way that
we do that but it's the wrong way to do
that and I and I think that like you
know realizing that figuring it out and
helping other people figure it out is a
really good thing to be doing if you can
but of course also sometimes you can't
this reminds me of the vlogbrothers
video I wrote in about how people should
stop making fun of Kim Kardashian
because she's a person and her feelings
matter and I sent it to Hank and
rosianna and they were like this is not
the hill that you want to die on I think
Kim Kardashian's ego is okay like at the
moment I don't know man I the whole idea
I don't know
the whole idea that people feel
completely comfortable punching up
because those people have infinite
resources to deal with the fact that
you're punching up at them I just don't
buy it maybe partly because I've been
punched up at but I don't I don't buy it
alright John well you know enough with
the the silly easy questions let's get a
real a real Tuffy here it's from Brian
who asks dear Hank and John as Halloween
is approaching I find my anxiety growing
stronger I don't like Halloween but my
office dresses up I don't want to be
that guy and show up to work with no
costume and be a buzzkill but I also
don't want to go through the effort to
celebrate a holiday I don't care about
should I quit my job call in sick write
book on my face like Jim Halpert not
Ryan but Brian Brian I feel you here I
do not like dressing up for Halloween
I'm 41 years old I'm not in the
steam business I'm not like my brother
prancing around as dr. Lawrence
turtleman I like I bought the clothes
that I bought because I'm comfortable in
them and I like wearing them I don't
want to like wear them 364 days and then
the other day dress up like Woody from
Toy Story
is this like John has never had the
thought finally I get to be more
expressive in my clothing actually I
didn't even understand that idea until
just now when you expressed it to me in
a language that made sense yeah I think
calling in sick is not a terrible idea
that I totally days right yeah like go
to a thing go do you like indulge in a
thing that you like doing whether that's
like like staying home and reading a
book or going to the go-kart place and
owning all the the little
twelve-year-old celebrating their
birthdays some of those 12 year olds you
can't compete with because they weigh so
much less sure it is a function of
acceleration I was go karting recently
and this absolutely snotface 12 year old
past me in humiliating fashion then
slowed down to let you past them and the
best me again like I like that let's do
it again yeah I can do this whenever I
want nerd yeah Brian go go-karting
that's a great solution that's a great
Halloween tradition you just have to
build your own Halloween traditions so
you know like people who don't celebrate
Christmas sometimes they'll go out for
lunch and then watch a movie by
themselves or something on Christmas Day
you just got to build your own Halloween
traditions so that eventually you will
love Halloween you just won't love it in
the way that everyone else loves it you
won't be like into the trick-or-treating
part of Halloween you'll have your own
Halloween rituals I think that's a great
solution if Brian doesn't want to do
this and does want to go to work is
there a costume that Brian can wear that
is is like people see it and they're
like oh well done but also it's just his
normal clothes no that's the problem
because all those low-effort the whole
problem with Halloween is that high
effort costumes are good and
effort cost yeah all bad yeah oh god I
hate Halloween
Oh Brian you're stressing me out
reminding me that Halloween is coming
god I like dress I got my kids are gonna
want me to do something and they're
gonna well dad why don't you dress a lot
and then you maybe put on a witch hat
and everyone's like oh that's not a
costume that's just a witch hat and
you're like oh I don't I don't want to
change pants for this event one thing
you might try Brian is going so hard on
your Halloween costume that you
humiliate everyone else in the office
and they just quit
Halloween forever you know like like
yeah yeah like it could you get could
you get one year for there to be a rule
the person who wins the Halloween
costume contest gets to decide the
future of Halloween costume practices
and the way that I would suggest going
super hard for Halloween is I would
suggest going to work as the rock you
know Dwayne the rock Johnson uh-huh but
instead of like getting like a muscle
suit or whatever I would just hire
Dwayne the rock Johnson to go to your
work on Halloween and just wear your
clothes wear your clothes and he's just
absolutely busting out of them and he
knows enough about your life he's a good
actor he's a really good actor actually
that he can just follow along you know
and you can just just make your office
believe like wow Bryan like became the
rock for a day and then everyone will be
like ah how eanes no good anymore it's
the Bryan's too good at it I love the
idea of paying someone to go to your
Halloween party for you just anyone and
like oh you don't have to you could just
hire a local actor and to pretend that
they're you yeah yeah just gives you do
every day at work I don't think so I
think it's an interesting idea Victor I
need to pay you to act like you're a
database consultant wait Hank I think we
might be onto something
what if you paid a local actor $28,000 a
year to do your $32,000 a year job
then you got 14 jobs I think and you got
14 jobs but your main job was just
managing yeah we're now just a manager
yeah that's actually essentially what
businesses are graduations John you've
created capitalists I've created the
limited liability corporation Brian I
think we solved your problem now you're
gonna have to hire 400 actors to do 400
different jobs for a slightly lower rate
of pay than you are being paid to do
them congratulations on your new
business all right Hank this next
question comes from Alison who writes
dear John and Hank in my high school we
watch a lot of crash course videos in
one of my classes I thank your teacher
for us Alison the problem is that my
entire school thinks that Hank is
actually John I don't see the problem I
realized this way either I I realized
this when we watched one one day and a
kid in my class asked if Hank was that
guy who wrote The Fault in Our Stars and
everyone just agreed that he was I knew
that the person in the video was
actually Hank but it was too awkward for
me to say anything about it and I
figured it would never come up again but
now when we watch crash course videos my
teacher will introduce the Hank ones as
being made by John Green the author of
The Fault in Our Stars is it my
responsibility as someone who knows who
Hank is to tell my class that Hank is
not John or should I just let my school
continue to think that Hank and John are
the same person thanks for the help
Alison man I like I get this a lot I
guess a lot if people would be like when
is your new book coming out and I'll be
like well it's my first book and they're
like no it's not and I'm like okay yeah
I did it'll be a weird conversation
we're about to have I'd rather just let
you keep believing it
when I met Neil deGrasse Tyson he very
helpfully said to me now are you the
science one or the other one I love that
so much do you feel very good if you
happen to come across us in public and
you want to say hi I feel free to do so
but don't if you're if you're trying to
guess which one you've got the best way
to ask is are you
science wonder the are you the other one
honestly nobody gets to be the author of
The Fault in Our Stars except John Green
and that's not fair so why not have two
people get to get to be that yeah no I I
agree with you but not in a way that
makes me want to share the royalties
yeah it doesn't bother either of us I
think I was at the movies the other day
and somebody walked up to me and pointed
at me and said Hank green right and I
was like uh I mean I'm trying to pee and
get back to the movie but on the other
hand I don't know if I can let this
misinformation stand and I was like ah
no I'm his brother and they were like oh
I'm so sorry and I was like it's really
it's not a big deal and they're like no
I'm so sorry like of course I know that
it's just and I was like it's really I
really it's not a big it's really not a
big deal like I like my brother it's
fine I walked into a bar one time like
you know it's bar it's a bar it's dark
and a guy like at the bar looks over at
me punched me with both fingers and he
says vsauce like good enough yeah do I
look like maybe that's what we should do
Hank maybe you should just accept it no
matter what
which reminds me John that this podcast
is brought to you by vsauce vsauce it's
real good internet video of today's
podcast it's also brought to you by the
Surgeon General the Surgeon General I
mean you should not smoke and this
podcast is brought to you by ask dr.
Dorf ask dr. Dorfman brand-new comedy
podcast about optimal ology and finally
today's podcast is brought to you by
this car contains a diversity of
opinions a real bumper sticker that we
just invented that is available for
pre-order at dftba.com right now Hank
you're not busy do you mind designing
this car contains a diversity of opinion
I just designed a bunch of an absolutely
remarkable thing merch and I was just
like this is what I'm doing this is like
my like watching the Great British Bake
Off
designing merch huh it's fine that's
good I also figured think it's weird to
design merch for a prop for a book that
nobody's read yeah Here I am well I work
it's I think it's good that you are
focusing on something other than the big
huge ball of stress in front of you
which most of which you can do nothing
about
correct correct we also have a project
for awesome message d from texas donated
to the project for awesome to get us to
say this only part of which i still
agree with donating was a special moment
for me for the last few years i've been
fighting to make it when the journey
started to feel so Sofie and I
remembered John's proclamation over time
the overall size of the pizza gets
bigger so even if your slice is small
you will ultimately get more whenever I
became disheartened I clung to the truth
resists simplicity d thank you for
donating to the project for awesome and
I'm so happy that you're finally in a
position to donate to the project for
awesome I will say when I made that
video I was pretty sure that I was right
and I'm not sure that I was right now
because despite the fact that the
overall economy has grown quite a lot in
the last 20 years wages have not grown
at all so it seems like there are times
at least where wages stay very stagnant
even as the economy grows so hopefully
that is something that will get better
in the future
but it's not gonna get better unless we
do something about it alright John we
got another question this one comes from
Connor who asks dear Hank and John I've
been something of a regular at a
Starbucks near my home but I'm not sure
I can ever go back yesterday when one of
the baristas asked me if my cups needed
sleeves I answered that it was already
hot out and I thought didn't think that
they would need sleeves after a pause
she laughed but it could very easily
have been out of pity how do you return
to a place where you've embarrassed
yourself by making a terrible dad joke
nobody puts Baby in the Conner you've
just made another one even way worse
well like how do you return to this
podcast after that name specific
sign-off well this is a great question
for Hank because he faces this problem
on a weekly basis it's all about it's
all about being confident and your dad
Joe could my friend you gotta be proud
of whatever whatever giggle you extract
from anyone even if it's a pity giggle
[Laughter]
that's it
that is the answer this next question
comes from Cheyenne who writes Dear John
and Hank my roommate is a friend who
likes to stop by unannounced and things
are starting to get out of hand
the last few times she's shown up my
roommate hasn't even been home but she
has to take a bus to get here so it's
weird to turn her away at the door
it's midnight now and I really want to
go to bed but she's still here oh she
just spent the last hour pouring her
heart out to me about how she has
trouble making friends because she's
incredibly sensitive and is going
through some serious health problems so
I feel bad kicking her out how should I
let her know that it's time to leave
without hurting her feelings
oh boy Cheyenne Cheyenne this is a
proper problem but I have to first tell
you a story about a friend of mine who
shall remain nameless
so Cheyenne my first apartment in
Chicago which I shared with three
roommates had a door that was locked and
none of us had the key so we came and
went
usually through a back window which
sounds weird now but at the time you
know we were 22 it didn't seem that
weird
I don't know must have seemed weird
right it that's very weird you feel
weird to be anyway one day I come home
and sitting on my couch is a friend of
mine from high school whom I have not
seen in six years and my friend is
watching the Cubs game and I walk in
through the back window as usual and I
see my friend watching the Cubs game
eating honey nut cheerios out of the box
my honey nut cheerios and he just looks
up at me and he says hey John and we
hung out for about three hours he was in
town for something wanted to see a
concert hung out for about three hours
he went to his concert I have not seen
him since how did he find your window
but I am waiting I am waiting for the
day when I come to my house after work
and he's sitting there watching a Cubs
game eating what is now probably
cinnamon life because that's what my
kids like
uh yeah I haven't eaten cereal out of
the box and way too long
well it's good it's a pleasure that
sounds great that sounds great it's a
Saturday morning Joyride car cartoons
and serials straight out of the box
Saturday morning Joyride but Cheyenne
you actually had a question which is a
toughy and I I think that they're like
this person is probably like reading
your signals but not wanting to read
them so it's not really a problem of you
sending the wrong signals probably
you've said like I'm getting really
sleepy and you've yawned a bunch and
it's still happening because this person
is looking for someone to lean on and is
desperate for that and you are the
person who is there right but you can't
hold it
you can't hold this person's problems
you can't be this person's solution and
so I I would think you need to talk
first to your roommate because your
roommate is the extensible friend here
your roommate is the person who has the
pre-existing relationship I think you
need to talk to your roommate and say
look this person is coming by a lot
they're staying late they're coming by
unannounced and that's not great yeah
yeah and it is sort of a like there's
been a couple of times in my life where
someone has has kind of intentionally
stayed until the chance for them to
leave has ended and then they're like
well I can't go home now all of the
people who have cars left and it's like
I feel like you made that decision and
so I made the decision to come to this
place not know it like like to sort of
put them in the situation where it's
hard for them to leave despite the fact
that they didn't tell anybody that they
were coming it is kind of a manipulative
behavior that's not to say that they
don't have legitimate problems and like
that they don't need help they probably
do and and and the ways in which you are
providing that support is good work and
you're doing that but you are not
required to do it any more than you
already have
yeah it's tough though I mean it is
tough and I and I think that you
absolutely like you should do what you
and for this person but like you should
also go to sleep sometime yeah you got
to take care of yourself too
in fact you got to take care of yourself
first all right Hank one more question
before we get to the all-important news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon this
question comes from Rachel Dear John and
Hank I recently had to have a rib
removed Oh my surgeon let me keep my rib
[Laughter]
what does that look like
do you want your rib or do you Sadie who
brought it up I want to know who brought
it up I I have a totally different take
on this which is of course the surgeon
let you keep your rib it's your rib just
because the surgeon cut it out of you
doesn't make it theirs I think that like
yeah I'm not expecting the surgeon to
take it home I don't want that I don't
want the surgeon to have a collection of
ribs but I do oh yeah great point Hank
if there is a surgeon out there with a
collection of ribs they should be
immediately removed from surgery forever
that's one reason to keep your rib is to
just prevent the exactly the hoarding
instinct that some people might have to
be like well I've got to I might as well
have more I guess this is my collection
now it's like when your grandma gives
you like to to like little antique glass
candy jars and then suddenly that's your
thing I mean I would argue it's not
exactly like that but I see the analogy
the thing is you choose to bring home
that first rib if you're a surgeon and
that choice is very weird
yeah
Rachael back to your question how do i
appropriately artfully display my rib oh
god what suggested scrimshaw or that i
carve a picture onto my rib I think I
should just frame it and call it spare
rib what are your suggestions PS
attached is a picture of my rib in a jar
and I have to say it's bigger than I
expected
yeah it is
hunka bone let's see I don't think that
you are gonna develop the the techniques
necessary to scrimshaw your own rib I
just don't think that I don't like for
this one task unless you like want this
to be something that you do more of you
scrimshaw other people's ribs I think
probably you're gonna want to give your
rib to a professional scrimshaw art so I
totally I totally agree with you you go
to the person who already has developed
a talent for scrim showing human ribs
no no just not human ribs just
Eddie scrimshaw at all don't invent the
wheel on this wood Rachel have you
talked to your surgeon about the
possibility that they might be an
expertise from showing ribs
they have good fine motor skills
presumably let's hope boy oh boy I I'm
glad that you have your rib it might
just be for the closet no no no no no
it's definitely for display the more you
could make it look like an art piece the
better it gets the less it looks like it
was your rib and I have to say looking
at this picture with your ribbon a jar
it looks a lot like it was your rib the
more you can do to kind of make it feel
like art the better it's gonna work when
people are like oh tell me about that
piece and you're like oh that's called
spare rib it's my rib you need to get
like a lot of sculpture you know so
there's a big wall of sculpture in your
house and people will be and you can be
like this is a pot from the Indus Valley
Civilisation or this of course is a bowl
from Han China and this is spare rib my
rib vive rimshot by legendary scrimshaw
artist my surgeon dr. Dorf what a great
doctor tours callback oh my gosh sure
because he's he works on ribs - all
right Hank it's time for the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon the news this week from the
world's favorite third tier English
football team the two pieces of news
first off Hank as you recently found out
a F
Wimbledon has a new training kit sponsor
the sponsor of Wimbledon's training kits
is an absolutely remarkable thing a hit
new novel coming out September 25th and
available for pre-order now thank you
John
that's very cool and weird and I very
cool it weird I tried to focus most of
the sponsorships on things that you like
and you would be proud of and not make
it too much of a homework gift but yeah
just couldn't pass up the opportunity to
sponsor those those training kits not
least because Wimbledon just needs extra
money before we get into the new stadium
so anyway happy to do it
I do prefer the sponsorship of the Dutch
national Quidditch team personally and
also all of the robotics teams which is
just genius but but also thank you for
my FC Wellington sponsorship well you're
welcome
AFC Wimbledon in football league 1
played Gillingham last week and we won
we won 1 to nil which is great it means
we kept a clean sheet and we won the
game so all around a good result playing
against Barry Fuller which was difficult
he was he played a great game actually
but we did win the game we won on a goal
from Joe Piggott you know what the
Wimbledon fans sing when Joe Piggott
scores
Hank coming John they sing feed the pig
feed the pig feed the pig and he will
score is it true it's true if you feed
the pig he scores all right thanks a lot
it was Hank that win means that AFC
Wimbledon have risen up from 20th all
the way to the dizzying heights of 13th
in the league 1 table 8 points after 7
games
Hank what is the news from Mars this
week we're just gonna go with some some
fancy like Mars fan news John yeah an
artist and PhD candidate in the
Netherlands studying the formation of
Jupiter's moons Nick Oberg created what
might a mission to Mars on the the
spacex big falcon ship look like on the
inside
so as we you know have like seemed that
there's a lot of space inside
of the potential ship capsule for the
the big Falcon rocket the you know
what's gonna actually be inside of there
is totally unknown and a mystery and we
don't have any way of like you know
planning that but this artist took it on
himself to just plan it out and and see
how those those uh cubic inches would
all be used and it's got everything from
vines growing on it to produce a little
bit of oxygen but also for aesthetic
value it's got a guy sitting on his
space toilet
it's got bunk rooms for people it's got
transmission systems it's got everything
you need for a trip to Mars it's even
got a little a greenhouse for growing
some leafy vegetables which everybody's
gonna want you know it so I when I was
growing up these cutaways of spaceships
like like there were like these big
books of spaceship cutaways would always
be like so detailed and beautiful and
weird and you could spend so much time
looking at them and finding new things
that what I saw this I loved it and if
you want to see it you can you can look
up Nicole Berg's name he's done a lot of
Mars art and has a really big bones
website that has all of that bars art on
it so it suggests you do that just i
probably if you just google Nick Oberg
it's OB ERG you can find it so thanks to
Nick for doing some cool art and if you
want to delve into it you can also see
an article about it at insider which is
that this is insider comm it is pretty
cool but the main thing it makes me
think Hank is that it seems like it's
gonna be very crowded in there I mean so
much less crowded than previous missions
but yeah you are gonna be in there for a
year with your friends so I mean in it's
like being in there like a 400 square
foot apartment for a year with your
friends which is why they've done
experiment putting people in small
containers and having them sort of stuck
for years at a time together and figured
out how people can and can't get along
in those situations
astronauts are different from me
yeah they are John I just I just learned
that all of the not all of the
astronauts but many Apollo astronauts
ate moon dust just they didn't they
don't they they had done no chemical
analysis on it they didn't know what it
was they just tasted it they just licked
the moon and I was like there is no one
less like John in the world what a
terrible idea I can't like like they
like get their hands dirty with moon
dust and then go back into the spaceship
take off their spacesuits and lick their
hands of the sixties okay Hank I sure am
glad I'm not going to Mars thank you for
potting with me it has been a pleasure
as always thanks to all of you for
listening if you want to email us you
can do so at Hank and John at gmail.com
we need your questions it's how we make
the pod this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins it's produced by
rosianna halse rojas and sheridan Gibson
our head of community and communications
this Victoria Bongiorno the music that
you're hearing is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]